لطالما كان لدي اهتمام بالفضاء
بدءًا من طفولتي كنت مفتونًا
بقصص الخيال العلمي باك روجرز حتى
سلسلة فلاش جوردون ليس مع الكثير في
المنطقة الغريبة ولكن بالتأكيد في
السفر عبر الفضاء والعيش على كواكب أخرى
هذا هو  الذكرى الخمسين
للتصوير في نفس الوقت الذي
هبط فيه الإنسان على سطح القمر أمريكا وأعتقد
أن العالم كان مفتونًا
بالمساكن منخفضة التكلفة التي من شأنها أن توفر
للجماهير التي ستكون مسبقة الصنع
ويمكن شحنها من حولها  كان
مفتونًا أيضًا باستخدام
البلاستيك البلاستيكي بشرط أن يكون
الجادة الرائعة التي كانت منخفضة التكلفة ولا تحتاج
إلى صيانة حيث كان يتم الإعلان عنها وهيكلية خفيفة الوزن
وقوية وسهلة الشحن.
طُلب من سيرنان ، وهو مهندس معماري فنلندي ،
أن يصمم كوخًا جبليًا وجد بعد
ذلك أنها تحظى بشعبية كبيرة
على الرغم من أنها لا تحظى بشعبية حيث
كانت المقصورة الجبلية في فنلندا الناس  هناك
اعتقدوا أنه كان مصدر إحراج
للبيئة هذه المركبة الفضائية البلاستيكية
على الرغم من أن الناس في جميع أنحاء العالم
أصبحوا مهتمين حقًا
بالأخوة وأقلعت في الولايات المتحدة
حاليًا ، يُقدر أنه
ربما يكون هناك ما يقرب من 50 من هذه المركبات التي تكسب
وجودًا  أكثر مما
لم يتم العثور عليه ببساطة أنني أشك في
أننا نعتقد أن قابلية العيش في المستقبل
أمر لا يصدق ، نفتح الباب الأمامي
ولا توجد ذرة من الغبار
هنا لأن النوافذ
غير قابلة للتشغيل مع خروج أختام الباب
جحيم مجاني ولكن من الرائع ما
تم الإعلان عنه لعائلة مكونة من أربعة أفراد ،
لكنهم مصممون دائمًا ليكونوا نوعًا من
مقصورة تزلج جبلية ليست
كإقامة دائمة ،
مساء الخير ، أنتجت حرب الشرق الأوسط
تطورات في جميع أنحاء العالم
اليوم  قررت الدول المنتجة للنفط
في العالم العربي استخدام نفطها
كسلاح سياسي عندما كان الحظر النفطي المفروض
عليه كان له تأثير كبير على تكلفة
النفط الخام وأسعاره.  أصبحت المواد البلاستيكية المصنوعة
من هذا تُعرف باسم
مرسيدس-بنز للمساكن الجاهزة
، ومن ثم تتظاهر إلى حد كبير
بتصنيع المزيد من
المواد التي لم تعد موجودة للتو
لأننا نحتفل
بالذكرى الخمسين لكلا هذين الحدثين
المستقبل ، كونك تبلغ من العمر 50 عامًا
وخطوة ذراعك على القمر ، يجب أن
تكون حارسًا لهذه الموارد ،
فهذا يمنحك إحساسًا رائعًا
بالمكان عندما تكون هنا أنك
حقًا في مكان خاص لن
يكون أبدًا  خلقت أنا أفعل
[موسيقى]